[Música]
primer acto llega un alumno un
estudiante de una universidad privada en
el norte del país y llega a mi oficina
con un montón de papeles un montón de
papeles una torres y con estudios con
modelos de negocio con un montón de
cosas porque un día vio en las noticias
y empezó a ver en redes sociales que en
una zona un polígono de pobreza en esa
misma comunidad había un problema en la
zona citrícola entonces a él se le
ocurrió una excelente idea de poner algo
ahí una organización hizo un modelo
negocio y todo entonces empiezo a ver
eso nada muy bien y al momento que le
pregunto simplemente oye pues pero está
muy padre todo lo que preparaste qué
opina la gente de ahí y te acercado y la
respuesta que me sorprendió fue que
jamás en su vida se había parado en ese
lugar nunca había hablado con nadie se
me recordó muchísimo público fue así
como si yo tengo la solución y todo va a
ser y pongo ya va a quedar todo
segundo acto
llegue una empresa con su departamento
de responsabilidad social corporativa y
empieza a poner plantas en diferentes
zonas de otra ciudad industrial en el
norte del país llega a una colonia muy
conocida muy emblemática y como quiere
ser parte de la comunidad de que la
comunidad sea parte de lo que ellos
están haciendo en un parque en que vea y
desde es como la vida de esa colonia y
deciden tirar todo en el parque y como
traen ideas bien innovadores y son
chavos empiezan a poner un parque para
las personas que puedan patinar y para
que dan clases de parkour y todo cuando
están construyendo esto se dan cuenta
que 78% de los habitantes de esa colonia
eran adultos mayores de 65 años entonces
y no nada más eso sino que les encantaba
su parque y les encantaba salir a
caminar y les encanta sentarse en sus
bancas
tercer acto
llegan un nuevo secretario de transporte
público a una ciudad
es una persona muy preparada bien es de
las mejores universidades del mundo
viene con muchos estudios con mucho
respaldo se ha publicado en grandes
cantidad jamás en su vida ha sido que ha
estado en un puesto público y cuando le
preguntan los reporteros que hay un caos
en la movilidad de la ciudad porque
piensa ser y dice pues no pero la verdad
jamás me ha subido un transporte público
pero pues viendo lo que dice la gente en
redes sociales que pueda que hace mucho
calor que necesitan un aire
acondicionado con eso se soluciona toda
la movilidad la ciudad
y ya ha solucionado
como seamos la hora
chan chan chan podría decir mil maneras
como se podría llamar esta obra pero
como queremos que esta plática sea
familiar mejor ahí le dejamos y voy a
decir lo que si no es lo que como como
no se llama definitivamente no son
modelos sociales y programas sociales
funcionales no sirven
por cierto
porque hola soy aquí y me lo han
presentado soy comunicólogo y consultor
de innovación social de hace más de 12
años diseñó programas de responsabilidad
social para grandes empresas y ayudo a
muchos gobiernos a diseñar programas ya
ubicarlos un poquito mejor para que
tengan mejor impacto y a organizaciones
a tener un modelo más sostenible
me encantaría decir que estos tres actos
que acaban de pasar son un chiste porque
así parece pero créanme que son muy
reales y los vemos más a menudo de lo
que me gustaría verlo es muy natural ver
el mundo desde nuestra óptica personal
nuestra nuestra visión del mundo al
final se empieza a componer por la
educación que tuvimos por las personas
que están alrededor y que frecuentamos
cotidianamente por lo que vemos por lo
que consumimos en redes sociales por por
todo eso y vamos hablando un contexto
personal contexto personal y desde ese
palco de nuestro contexto personal vemos
el mundo y vemos unilateralmente
pensando que absolutamente todo es así
y pongo muchísimo énfasis en esa palabra
contexto que al final el contexto lo
podemos entender como un conjunto de
circunstancias que envuelven a una
situación específica pero si la de las
cuales a lo mejor no podríamos entender
perfectamente qué es lo que está pasando
hace años diseñando cuando recién
empezaba en este mundo del impacto
social
me tocó diseñar un programa para una
zona un polígono muy violento en el sur
del país
yo según sabía todo lo que pasaba ahí me
leí todos los informes que había de
todas partes
melià estudios y mejores prácticas
entonces cuando llegó como este chavito
del primer ejemplo con toda mi mochila
con todas las cosas según yo con toda la
solución de lo que iba a pasar o
sorpresa
ahorita algo que no era tan sorpresa me
doy cuenta que la realidad sobrepasaba
lo que cualquier informe cualquier libro
podría decir y podría reflejar era mucho
más yo no lo había enfrentado y no podía
dimensionar lo que estaba pasando pues
desde un libro
ahí descubrí el diseño participativo que
también se llama de diseño cooperativo
es poner todo el enfoque y enfocar a
todas las personas que están alrededor
de una problemática a buscar una
solución en conjunto en consenso es bien
difícil es tener tantas voces que están
diciendo una sola cosa
todo y todo el mundo quiere opinar al
mundo quiere decir es complicado pero el
secreto y la regla que nos ha funcionado
ahí es tener las reglas bien claras
desde el principio y un propósito
compartido y consensuado el primer
momento
justo allí cuando empiezas a trabajar
todo eso te das cuenta que con relación
no necesariamente implica causalidad
empiezas a ver las circunstancias y todo
el contexto que está alrededor con este
diseño participativo me encanta que este
concepto de diseño participativo
cooperativo actualmente se está usando
en diferentes áreas no nada más en el
impacto social en el diseño software en
el diseño de marca en el diseño de
productos hasta en el ámbito de salud se
está usando para generar lugares y
habitaciones más sensibles y más
adecuadas para todos los pacientes
entonces cuando cuando uno se empieza a
clavar entenderlo el contexto a meterse
un poquito más con lo que está pasando
alrededor uno se da cuenta con la
realidad de frente y puedes ver que
cuando un problema no tiene solución
pues a lo mejor ni siquiera es un
problema es una característica y lo
empieza a dimensionar de manera
diferente y empieza a trabajar de manera
diferente ya nada más no piensas como el
teórico que es bien importante sino
también piensas como el práctico
y un ejemplo bien claro
es estos vecinos esta fue la colonia que
les dije en el ejemplo me encantó porque
actualmente los vecinos se empezaron a
orientar no les gustó lo que él pasó se
empezaron a conjuntar se empezaron a
hacer reuniones empezaron a llamar a
estos técnicos expertos porque sabían lo
que están haciendo la parte técnica cosa
que ellos no sabían pero yo sabía en la
parte vivencial ellos vivían allí tenían
todo el mundo sabía lo que estaba
pasando cuando unieron fuerzas empezaron
a gestionar políticas públicas que para
mí por ejemplo de mi experiencia es uno
de los mejores ejemplos de lo que está
pasando o también tenemos a fundación
tierra de artistas por ejemplo que es
una organización de voluntariado
profesional que trae gente de todo el
mundo de diferentes especialidades de
diseño de arquitectura de comunicación
de mercadotecnia y van a la comunidad a
diferentes comunidades del mundo de perú
en españa en mexico y diseñan juntos
diagnostican juntos gestionan juntos lo
que tiene que pasar en ese entonces
traen a la parte técnica que sabe sabe
arrastrar el lápiz y sabe lo que tiene
que ser pero quien mejor que conoce la
comunidad y las problemáticas que están
pasando hoy
y es entonces cuando entendemos
perfectamente y cuando empezamos a ver
así
todo todo lo que está pasando en
contexto todo lo que está pasando en las
situaciones y empezamos a diseñar con
todo esto
entendemos que si si es bien importante
arrastrar el lápiz desde un escritorio
porque necesitamos números necesitamos
métricas
necesitamos diagnósticos necesitamos
todo esto pero también sobre todo cuando
estamos trabajando con personas
necesitamos remangarnos un poquito la
camisa ponernos unos zapatos cómodos y
salir a la realidad a lo cotidiano a lo
que está pasando ahí ver cómo se mueven
las dinámicas sociales de todo lo que
estamos haciendo y es entonces cuando
estamos ahí que esos números que salen
en un reporte se convierten en juan se
convierten en maría se convierten en el
mundo se convierten en alma le ponemos
voz les ponemos cara les ponemos una
personalidad le ponemos una visión del
mundo le ponemos un propósito de vida y
es entonces y sólo entonces cuando
empezamos a diseñar entendiendo que nada
es para la comunidad sin la comunidad
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e